Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Il y a quelques années,
mon médecin m’a dit :
« Marie-Laure, autant
que je sois franc avec vous.
Il y a trois effets secondaires
à votre maladie
le chômage, le célibat et la dépression. »
Bam ! Ça, c’est fait.
Ça fait drôle quand même.
On se prend trois uppercuts d’un coup.
Alors, on respire et on encaisse.
J'ai une pelade universelle.
C’est une maladie auto-immune
dont l’unique effet apparent,
c’est la perte totale
des cheveux et des poils.
En clair, mes globules blancs
pensent que mes follicules pileux
sont un corps étranger et les rejettent.
C’est balaise, n’est-ce pas ?
Et ça fait quatorze ans que ça dure.
Ma diversité à moi, c’est d’être chauve.
Mais pour d’autres, ça peut être
une dyslexie, un œil de verre
ou être parent d’un enfant autiste.
Des diversités invisibles
mais loin d’être insignifiantes.
Personnellement, j’ai d’abord
choisi de cacher ma différence,
de passer inaperçue,
de me fondre dans la masse.
Je n’avais pas conscience à ce moment-là
de ce que ça allait me coûter.
Quand on parle du coût, on pense
tout de suite au coût financier.
Il y a les perruques,
très peu remboursées pour la pelade,
parce que la Sécu considère
que c’est uniquement esthétique.
Et puis, il y a le tatouage
des sourcils entre autres.
Et en quatorze ans,
j’ai dépensé pas moins de 26 000€.
Il y a aussi le coût professionnel,
le coût de carrière.
Quand on cache sa différence,
on doit parfois jongler
avec des contraintes qu’on ne
peut pas avouer à son employeur.
J’ai eu des traitements,
jusqu’à trois fois par semaine.
Je n’ai jamais été en arrêt
maladie à cause de ça.
J’ai toujours performé et
atteint mes objectifs annuels.
J'ai même souvent été parmi
les meilleurs de ma boîte.
Et pourtant, j’ai entendu des remarques :
« Mais quand même,
tu pars tôt pour un cadre. »
C’est vrai, mais quand j’arrivais tard
ou que je partais tôt
pour un rendez-vous médical,
je reprenais l’ordi le soir à la maison.
Je n'ai jamais failli.
Mais quand les bruits courent
en entreprise, ils sont tenaces.
Il y a aussi le coût identitaire.
Quand on a une différence physique,
quand on voit son corps se modifier,
quand on passe plus de la moitié de
son temps à cacher qui on est vraiment,
on se demande : « Qui suis-je ? »
Il y a la Marie-Laure du travail.
Bavarde, fonceuse, confiante,
performante, piquante même.
Mais le soir,
je rentre, je retire la perruque
et je me confronte à mon miroir.
Je suis chauve.
Et ce n’est pas seulement
le reflet qui est modifié,
ce sont également toutes
les représentations qu’il y a autour.
Apparaissent alors le manque
de confiance en soi, d’assurance,
la honte et parfois même le dégoût.
Et ce coût identitaire, pour moi,
se traduit par un coût d’authenticité
vis-à-vis des autres.
Quand je cache la pelade,
la personne que je suis
n’est pas forcément
celle que je donne à voir.
Imaginez,
c’est comme si chacun
de nous était un puzzle.
Au final, on donne à voir
certaines parties de celui-ci
qui permettent aux autres de cerner
globalement qui nous sommes.
Évidemment, nous omettons
tous des petites parties,
notre jardin secret.
Mais quand on cache une aussi grosse
partie, comme la pelade pour moi,
qui m’a construite,
qui a forgé ma personnalité,
qui m’a endurcie
et fragilisée en même temps.
Quand je cache cette part,
les gens se retrouvent avec un puzzle
avec un gros trou au milieu.
Une image biaisée, incomplète.
Certes, cette pelade ne me définit pas.
Je suis bien plus que ma pelade
mais elle fait partie de moi.
Les gens qui ne connaissent pas
cette part penseront parfois :
« Marie-Laure, on ne sait pas
trop qui elle est, en fait. »
Et ils ont raison,
il leur manque une partie du puzzle.
Un exemple.
Imaginez une journée team building
avec des jeux d’entreprise
dont l’un est un combat
en costume de sumo gonflable.
Mes collaborateurs viennent me voir :
« Il faut que tu le fasses.
C’est pour toi. »
Donc je fonce et je m’inscris.
Mais quand arrive mon tour,
quand je vois que le costume est
très étroit et s’enfile par la tête,
je vais chercher une collègue
pour qu’elle me remplace.
Parce que je sais que
si j’enfile ce costume,
ma perruque va se faire la malle.
Réactions des collègues :
« Tu encourages tout le monde à le faire.
Et toi, tu trouves une excuse
bidon pour ne pas le faire ? »
Avouez qu’en termes de leadership,
ce n’est pas terrible.
Vous voyez que finalement,
quand on décide de cacher sa diversité,
on en paye le prix.
Et tout ça engendre une perte de puissance
parce que l’énergie qu’on
met à cacher et à dissimuler,
on ne la met pas ailleurs,
on ne la met pas
dans la créativité ou dans l’innovation,
dans l’entrepreneuriat ou dans la famille,
dans les relations sociales
ou dans les projets.
Pourquoi j’ai caché ma différence
si ça me coûte autant ?
Parce que quand je vis telle
que je suis, c’est-à-dire chauve,
je me sens plus authentique et plus libre.
Mais ça me coûte aussi
dans les relations aux autres.
La pelade quand on en parle,
ce n’est rien :
« Qu’est-ce qu’elle dit ?
Ce n’est que des cheveux.
Il y a plus grave. De quoi
elle se plaint ? » C’est vrai.
Mais quand on la montre, cette pelade,
quand elle devient réelle,
ça dérange quand même et c’est normal
parce que ça vient nous titiller
sur un terrain qu’on n’aime pas.
J’ai vu les regards
de pitié et de confusion.
La perte de cheveux est connotée
au cancer et indirectement mort.
Alors, il y a cette réaction
chez certains :
« La pauvre, si jeune et si malade. »
ou encore le fameux :
« Ça va ? Tu es sûre ?
On peut décaler la réunion si tu veux.
- Mais oui, ça va, parfaitement bien,
aussi bien qu’hier.
Là, je suis juste venue sans cheveux. »
Et c’est pénible car on est reparti
pour cinq minutes d’explications
sur ce qu’est la pelade
et ça revient à me limiter à celle-ci.
Il y a la gêne souvent
qui fausse les relations.
J’ai remarqué qu’on ne me parle pas pareil
selon si je porte ma perruque ou non.
Parfois, sans cheveux,
on ne m’adresse même pas la parole.
Il y a l’incompréhension,
voire une question de légitimité.
On m’a souvent dit : « C’est bon,
c’est psychologique, ton truc.
Déstresse et ça va repousser. »
Ou encore : « Mais c’est bon, tu mets
une perruque et ça ne se voit pas. »
Ou le fameux et non moins maladroit :
« Tu verras, dans quelques années,
tu la remercieras, ta pelade,
ça va te changer.
Tu vas voir la vie autrement. »
Et puis, il y a le jugement.
L’amalgame de faiblesse.
Parce que dans l’inconscient collectif,
les cheveux sont un signe de force,
de puissance, de santé.
Voyez Hercule, Zeus,
Louis XIV, Jésus, les Vikings.
À l’inverse, les cheveux courts
ou rasés sont un signe de soumission,
voire d’humiliation.
Les militaires, les moines,
les prisonniers,
les tondues de la Libération.
Et tout ça,
c’est inscrit quelque part ici.
J’ai été amenée à parler de ma différence
à certains de mes employeurs
et je me souviens de leur réaction.
L’un d’eux a semblé
complètement indifférent.
Mais à partir de ce moment-là, toute
perspective d’évolution était bloquée.
Un autre l’a carrément verbalisé
en me répondant texto :
« Je ne savais pas que
j’avais embauché une faible. »
Incroyable, non ?
Et finalement, la pitié,
la gêne, le jugement,
tout ce que vous avez peut-être éprouvé,
de façon consciente ou inconsciente
depuis trois minutes,
c’est normal.
Ce sont les biais cognitifs en
chacun de nous qui nous amènent,
lorsqu’une situation est considérée
comme étant anormale,
à avoir d’abord un temps de surprise,
puis d’appréciation de la situation
et enfin de réaction.
Souvent de gêne parce qu’on
n’est pas préparé à cette situation
ou de minimisation pour nous
éviter d’avoir à y faire face.
Il serait utopique de croire
que chacun a la capacité
à accepter l’autre tel qu’il est.
Ce n’est pas si simple et
c’est en cela que j’ai moi aussi
ma part de responsabilité.
Parce que quand
je me montre telle que je suis,
sans avoir prévenu ni préparé l’autre,
je heurte sa sensibilité,
ses représentations et ses croyances,
comme j’ai peut-être heurté
les vôtres ici ce soir.
Et comme mécanisme de défense,
l’individu n’a d’autre choix
que de s’éloigner
de ce qui le met mal à l’aise.
Souvent de façon inconsciente d'ailleurs.
Alors, qu’est-ce qu’on en fait
de cette diversité invisible ?
On en parle, on la montre, on la cache ?
Pourquoi on cache
nos différences aujourd’hui ?
Pourquoi on se prive volontairement
de ce qui fait qui nous sommes,
de notre essence, notre authenticité
et notre avantage concurrentiel ?
Pour se conformer.
OK, mais à qui ? Aux autres.
D’accord, mais les autres
aussi cachent leurs différences
pour se conformer aux autres donc à nous.
On tient un truc là, non ?
Finalement, on est dans un cercle
qui continuera à s’auto-alimenter
tant qu’on en sera complice,
tant qu’on l’entretiendra.
La diversité invisible est partout.
Si chacun apporte sa différence
et si en même temps chacun a conscience
des mécanismes qui l’animent,
alors cette singularité devient banale.
Accepter sans même s'en soucier.
Qu’est-ce qui fait qu’on
la repère, cette diversité ?
C’est parce qu’elle est invisible
et parce qu’elle est atypique.
Mais si elle devenait banale.
Chauve, sourd d’une oreille,
daltonien, diabétique,
toutes ces différences,
si elles sont portées simplement,
ne seront plus que
les éléments visibles d’une société
qui assume sa diversité
comme une composante,
ni une force ni une faiblesse, juste
une composante d'une société vraie,
singulière et authentique.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)